hey guys what's up! we got a freak out
about ares i am so happy that he's
confirmed for the movie
oh thank god for toys so what's going on
here is the toy bear happened this past
week at the javits center in new york
that's where New York comic-con is every
year they show up all kinds of toys from
all the merchandisers that do stuff for
these big movies not just for the DC
people but for Marvel everything else
i'll talk about the Marvel stuff during
the Marvel videos that do because
there's some guardians of the galaxy
that they showed off we gotta look at ego
the Living Planet there's all kinds of
cool shut up and take my money stuff
that you'll be able to throw your money
at later this year. ares though I feel
like this is a breath of relief
everybody was wondering about ares of
the Wonder Woman movie he's such an
important person for a character that it
would have been weird for them to not
include him in the dceu so I'm
actually really happy about this but if
you're new to the channel i do DC videos
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything is going to be a bunch of
Wonder Woman stuff happening in the even
confirm the Justice League trailers
coming really soon so i'll talk about
that at the end of the video but
most of you if you read the new 52 or
you played injustice there's like a
couple different versions of the
character that we've seen lately in the
last five to six years the last
big-screen version of him was in the
2009 Wonder Woman animated movie you
might actually recognize the person who
is voicing this
it is only within this business and I am
truly document that
all
got it
not
forever
and Lord God I have a force of nature
you have address and shadow this diana
is why we can never reunite with the
outside world
that you can accept the nature of man as
it is
wicked
so even if you're not really familiar
with his powers and abilities because he
is a God he's a fully-fledged God with
all the powers that grants them in the
way that Wonder Woman is not she's more
of a demigod ares is the son of Zeus
and Hera wonder woman is the daughter of
Zeus and Hippolyta I know there's a
couple different versions of Wonder
Woman's origin story but ares is
usually the same so it doesn't really
change his towers the way they explained
in the DC EU is that she can't fly and
in the trailer she does say that she has
no father but technically her father is
Zeus he helped give life to her so she
does kind of have a father but it gets
really trippy so they're kind of mixing
and matching the comic book back story
so don't worry you don't have to read
like every single wonder woman comic
book that ever happened because ares is
actually pretty consistent just in the
way that his towers were where he comes
from what he can do but the really
interesting thing about him in this
movie is it looks like he's operating
behind the scenes so here's where we get
into like Harry Potter other Warner
Brothers IP stuff so supposedly David
Thewlis from the Harry Potter movies are
most of you remember him from those
movies he's done a lot of other stuff
but he's the one that's being credited
as ares because he doesn't sound like
he's seven feet tall in this fuckin
Schwarzenegger like dude what might end
up happening is because ares can take
whatever form that he wants is that
he'll start out looking like a normal
person and then eventually we'll get to
final boss form
video game logic that wonder woman faces
her final boss he has three different
forms so she better watch out i know
there's that moment in the trailer where
it seems like she's flying this look
that big weapon that's going off
they said that this is going to test the
limits of her abilities
she's actually going to see the full
extent of her powers but just because
when batman v superman came out they
said that wonder woman in this universe
doesn't slide I don't think that she's
actually flying at this moment something
else is going on she's jumping really
high but it's her solo movie so it just
makes sense that they're going to run
the gamut of this is where she comes
from this is what she can do this is
where she's headed in the future these
are the things that happen to her the
shape the way that she thinks these are
the big buildings that she's face like
that throwaway line from batman be
superman that was so cool where she says
I've killed things that are not from
this earth she might be talking about
aries because even though he's a god and
you can't kill God's wait for it you can
actually kill gods in the comics like
geoff johns did that big run called dark
side war where the new gods were killed
off and the Justice League got their
powers for a brief period and they
became gods themselves to those powers
were taken away of course you're selling
toys for wonder woman you want people to
buy it you're going to sell the coolest
version of the character so it looks
like the design that they've gone with
is modern air like post-crisis in slight
mix with injustice because a lot of the
costumes a lot of the universe does draw
some of the aesthetic from the injustice
universe even though that's not the
stories are going with always get a lot
of questions about injustice ever since
they debut that armored looking black
costume last year I've gotten so many
questions about the injustice universe
are they doing that in the movies is
that with the dcu is not exactly they're
just borrowing the aesthetics of edges
because it looks so much more hardcore
it's like the idea of Marvel's
ultimate's universe a more hardcore
version of the family-friendly Marvel
Universe the basic synopsis for Ares
reads very Greek tragedies he doesn't
like this is actually a translation so
it's like ninety-nine percent accurate
but it says why does is create the
Amazon ares is one of the biggest hits
in the world to restore harmony between
them
who's created the Amazon that area is
reduced to slavery the Amazons revolt
with the help of Zeus who will die at
the hands of his son having had time to
find some mascara their haven of peace
Diana Prince becomes Wonder Woman by
helping Steve Trevor in a squad of proud
Carmen law in search of one who wants to
white humanity off the map with deadly
gas so that confirms a couple of things
that we've seen from the trailers ares
is helping to destroy humanity through
Danny Houston's character who sort of
like the middle boss they're using small
boss dr. poison to develop this special
gas during World War one to kill off
everyone carries himself actually feeds
off of war it makes them stronger
negative emotions so the more people
fight the stronger he gets
he actually just his presence can make
people want to fight so even just
standing around in a crowd of people
it's really cool so you get the idea
from this backstory is that a lot of
people are worshipping area super
popular but its leading to the downfall
of humanity so Zeus tries to help them
by creating the Amazons to make peace
but then there's a big revolt ares ends
up killing his father very Greek tragedy
in the Amazons are hiding out on mascara
so that ares can't get to them so
everybody just wait out for final boss
form ares it's going to be a great
battle for Wonder Woman in Italy
interesting to see how they incorporate
the gods into the future deu movies
my guess is it just because there's a
lot of similarities in the ways that
Steppenwolf looks in the comics to Ares
is that Ares is the warm-up for
Steppenwolf injustice league in the
minions of dark side because if you
thought that one God was bad what about
a whole squad of them that are almost as
powerful it just be complete nightmare
which is why you need the Justice League
in those are the nightmares that Batman
has been having but there's also a bunch
of Justice League mother box stuff
that's happening that I'll talk about in
a separate video they updated the
synopsis for justice league just to be a
little more direct about why dark side
wants to attack the earth what
Steppenwolf is going to be doing like
what's the point of all this
so it's all about mother boxes will do a
video about that later this week let me
know in the comments what do you guys
think about ares how do you want them
to use them in the future movies
it sounds like if he doesn't die he's
going to slink back to the shadows but
what's gonna happen later tonight is
i'll post my flash gorilla City episode
after it airs so it's going to be crazy
and I'm also thinking about taking a day
of the week to always do DC videos for
the movies for the comics
let me know which day you want me to do
that on like I have Star Wars fridays i
want to pick another day or two for
different things like i'll have a day
that I just do spider-man video so let
me know which day of the week like maybe
thursdays or fridays along with star
wars that i always do DC stuff to give
away because it was such a big deal
there's a new round of the injustice to
give away i'm giving away a copy of the
game
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
congratulations to last week's injustice
giveaway winner calcific please private
message me on the back into my channel
so i can get your contact details the
new flash posted later tonight i'll see
you guys when I flew that video everyone
let's high-five while you wait that you
can click here to learn all about Grodd
and you can click here to learn all
about that Mystery Marvel Namor
project!